let's be honest Andrew it has been a
great year for stupid people it has yes
they've really flourished they have this
year yeah good on them more power more
power to the stupid well they have a lot
of power actually
every media Outlet in this country
almost particularly the BBC covered it
like it was a [ __ ] terrorist attack
front page front page news for two days
this this kind of legislation will
result in some sexual assaults so then
it comes down to well how many sexual
assaults of the s p prepared to accept
as collateral you can barely now see the
rainbow because there's so much [ __ ] on
the planet right and this and obviously
people are saying we're actually looking
at that now this looks kind of
homophobic this is Watergate level yeah
it's a selection interference by the FBI
of course right hugely it's got to be
the first sign of something creeping
into the authoritarianism when they
start changing definitions and forcing
you to accept their definitions and
that's the thing we've got to be really
wary of why is she constantly in the
press this year all the time I'm getting
really bored but that's also why people
are obsessed with Meghan Markle because
she is an actual princess complaining
about being oppressed yeah and people
are sick of it I've always said and
argued that the culture war is
key issue because it wins and loses
elections yes it determines the course
of history I mean the culture War has
escalated in this country since 2012
roughly and the Tories have been in
charge all of that time and they've made
it work the civil service is now out of
control but completely captured that's
the Machinery of government right there
and no one's doing anything about it
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People delighted to save for our final
year-end interview it is the one the
only returning for the 170th time to the
show he's a satrist writer author Andrew
Doyle welcome to technology I was any
honor a couple of months ago yeah I know
but yeah we got to do this Christmas
special review because let's be honest
Andrew it has been a great year for
stupid people it has yes they've really
flourished they have this year yeah good
on them more power more power to the
stupid people well they have a lot of
power actually yeah they really do yeah
and kind of a lot has been going on uh I
mean I don't want to talk about the more
recent stuff right now because we'll
talk about the Twitter files and we'll
talk about Jeremy Clark and all of that
more recent stuff but I think we
sometimes forget towards the end of the
year how much crazy [ __ ] happened
earlier in the year yes what have been
some of the highlights for you I mean
this has been a big year for the old
mermaids trans debate Tavistock Clinic
closing down people starting to wake up
to the problems that you know so all of
a sudden people have realized there's an
NHS funded clinic in London that is
effectively sterilizing gay children and
suddenly people realize that's not not
such a great thing but isn't it weird
that it took this long but this all came
about with mermaids as well taking on
LGB Alliance in court trying to strip
them of their charity status and then it
all crashing down on them because
suddenly people it's drawn attention to
the fact that one of their trustees has
written in support of pedophilic Desire
uh and the the CEO of mermaids took her
son to be castrated in Thailand at the
age of 16 and they've been sending
breast binders to children without their
parents consent and of course if you are
that dodgy as an organization maybe
don't go after another charity and draw
that much attention to yourself it's
going to be a light-hearted episode but
I was coming in on the festival
but you mentioned I mean Charities and
then going after people when you've got
some things to hide uh in Ghazi Fulani
uh interestingly her charity is now
being looked into and cozy planty that's
not her name is it no it's Marlene yeah
slightly less African yeah yes that's I
mean that's that's the thing so they're
going after her charity now as well it
turns out there's lots of dodgy stuff
there well maybe maybe allegedly
possibly chill out well I don't know but
we don't have the same legal team as
they do at gpus but but actually I mean
for people who may not have followed
that story because obviously we've got a
lot of people from abroad I actually
thought that story was a testament to
how utterly deranged our conversation
about race as countries become because
for people who don't know it was a story
about a woman who went to an event at
the palace uh with some minor royal
royal adjacent yes one of those
incestuous Germans exactly exactly and
she was asked repeatedly where she's
really from not necessarily the best
thing to ask somebody allegedly that's
what she was asking yeah and every media
Outlet in this country almost
particularly the BBC covered it like it
was a [ __ ] terrorist attack
front page front page news for two days
it's a bit mad isn't it but there's also
some very important details in that
story which is that the woman who kept
asking her where she's from was 83 years
old so she might have different ideas or
maybe less heightened awareness of
intersectional uh priorities right so
there's that but also she was 83 year
old Royal aide who's been like best
friend of the queen she's been involved
with the royal family for decades
um and part of her job if you turn up at
the palace as a guest part of the AIDS
job is to try and get information out of
you about you and your background so
that that information can be fed to
whichever Royal you're meeting so that
the conversation flows nicely right so
when she's saying where are you from I
actually need to know because I've got
to pass this information that's what
it's about it wasn't oh I don't believe
you because because you're black you
can't be from Britain that's a really
ungenerous assumption to make that
that's what she was talking about she
wasn't saying that at all also and gozie
Forlani which as we said real name
Marlene changed her name to this faux
African name and dressed in full
traditional African Garb right with
Africa shaped earrings oh I didn't know
about that yeah she had earrings with
the shape of Africa so if you completely
say that that's your identity and she's
free to identify however she wants and
she she identifies clearly as African
she connects with the country she
dresses as the country yeah she
accessorizes with the continent
um you know then someone's saying where
are you from and and you know that's a
reasonable question I think yeah you
know it's so it was bizarre it's the
whole thing was way over the top I think
it is rude right if if you ask them
where they're from and they tell you and
you you don't take that answer that is
kind of rude but I don't think that's
what was happening here didn't didn't uh
ngozi describe it as sustained racist
abuse wasn't something like that she
said it was traumatizing as well of
course she did yeah yeah yeah trauma is
very powerful is it like you get a lot
of points don't you for having trauma
and then she was so traumatized she went
back to educate uh the members of Staff
about yes and you know so it's a happy
ending in the end yeah exactly why not
just have this conversation anyway face
to face why not just why did she have to
put a transcript on Twitter and try and
get this person shamed I mean it's all
because
a massive media tour as well didn't she
yeah she went on a massive media tour
saying how she didn't want to draw too
much attention to the incident yes okay
which is what you do when you don't want
to draw too much attention you go on
good morning I mean I've had ghost
conversations with people regarding
sexuality people making assumptions
about me and stuff I don't put it all on
Twitter and try and get points but maybe
I should and thank you for that Andrew
yes I apologize it was really awkward it
made me feel very uncomfortable you know
particularly when you said that my
actions were against nature so that was
um a bit harsh I said not natural not
natural okay fair enough but you know I
think as human beings we're all going to
end up in these messy situations
sometimes and you often say something
you put your foot in it we all do yeah
you don't expect someone to be secretly
filming putting on Twitter let me get so
much cultural capital out of this as
possible and it also kind of degrades
the idea of racism doesn't it it sort of
suggests that actual racist incident so
On a par with this sort of imaginary uh
scenario and that's not good for
tackling actual racial Injustice either
so no one's a winner here no no one's a
winner and and the thing is as well
there was there was so much happening in
our country right and yet they focused
on this and you're like public services
are falling apart yeah but wherever the
media's obsessed with the royal family
of course so there's that so this was
this was a royal story so that you know
and they particularly at the moment are
obsessed with the royal family being
potentially racist because the whole
Meghan Markle thing which of course
another big thing this year why is she
constantly in the press this year all
the time I'm getting really bored of
hearing about it look to be fair Andrew
I'm going to call you out on this GB
news bloody love a bit of Megan well
that's not responsible for all of GB
news yes I I think I've spoken about her
a couple of times when there's been a
big story yeah relating like to the
Netflix documentaries and stuff like
that um so I'm happy to talk about but I
don't bang on about Meghan Markle at all
she's she's I think she may maybe 0.1
percent of my output it's based on Mega
Market I mean we can talk about it I do
I do find it quite funny that she keeps
getting caught in these incredible lies
yeah right which I just like you know
when she said
that she got married in secret a couple
of days before the wedding and the
archbish began to be officiated and then
the Archbishop said that's not true it
just didn't happen that's such a weird
although you know when she said she went
to the opening of The Lion King and the
the South African actor came up to her
and said Megan when you married Harry we
were dancing on the streets of Africa
just like when mandala and when Nelson
Mandela was released
um right and then it turns out that the
only South African actor in The Lion
King wasn't even at the premiere and has
never met her
so like just incredible lies and like
that kind of and that is funny like so
it's worth talking about just because
she's a fantasy that is quite funny I'm
not I'm not obsessed with them
I'm just not obsessed with the royal
family I'm just not really that
interested in them yeah you know but we
see racism in everything and that's
another thing I think that the reason
the palace responded in the manner that
they did was because they had spent six
or months or whatever however long it is
I don't follow it because I'm not
interested in it either being accused of
systemic racism by Harry and Megan
because they asked what color the baby
was going to be or speculated when it
when it when it appeared if they did I
mean I don't know who said what
Recollections may vary right we don't
know who said what what about it so it's
just not interesting an overheard
conversation by some Posh people will
never meet yeah why is that but also
Andrew this is the other thing that
people don't want to acknowledge but the
reality is in in all mixed families that
is what people talk about include like
when my son was about to be my wife and
I talked to us you're going to be like
me oil she's much like to skin them it's
what it's what people talk about right
it's the human thing do you know what I
mean yeah ask wondering what color your
Offspring or grandchildren might be is
the most natural human thing that exists
is it akin to say or will it have blue
eyes or brown eyes will it have webbed
feet that kind of thing yeah probably in
corn or maybe yeah yeah but like Francis
you know his mum is very dark his dad is
pasty Irish white skin why did you point
at me when you I have pasty skin
it's Grim your Northern Irish
it is a problem I I would you know I I
can burn at even the slightest contact
with the sun you know it's not good but
that but when you come from a mixed
background that's what people do like
when I went back to Venezuela people
always used to say to me why are you so
white
because everyone in my family is quite
pasty so we we don't have that
conversation actually they called me the
white monkey
but saying that I do have gingers in the
family yeah yeah if I were to have a
child I would probably speculate about
whether it would we would have to get
rid of it you know
that would be something that's not fair
isn't it
um but why not well it's just a bit mean
yeah it's a bit cheap
there has been a lot of other stuff
going on as well and yeah obviously
we're joking about all this stuff uh but
the trans issue for some reason I mean
you talk about you know we I feel we've
made a lot of progress in this country
this year on the one hand on the other
hand the SNP literally as we sit here
right now they've just pushed through a
bill in Scotland yeah tell us about that
well yeah that's not good um so the SMP
have been for a long time pushing the
idea of gender reform gender so that
people can self-ident ID as the gender
that they choose without so typically
you would have to live a period of time
if you are a transsexual person if
you're someone who for whatever reason
needs to uh have surgery or to present
to the opposite sex uh there are there
are there's protocol in place to do that
so that you can you know you can have
medical guidance Etc but now they're
saying I think that's three months so
you can just after three months just
declare it effectively and then lots of
feminists you must have seen the
protests outside Hollywood and lots of
feminists have been saying look the
thing about implementing self-id laws is
it leaves loopholes open to be exploited
by people who are who may have nefarious
agendas what they're not saying is that
trans people are predators or trans
people of a propensity for being uh
predatory they're not saying that at all
what they're saying is that if you are a
sexual predator you'll use any loophole
that you can and from the history of
sexual predators we know that to be the
case so sexual predators always claim to
be something that they're not to get
access to victims I mean that I could
cite a million examples of that um just
in the Litany of serial killers of
people who pretended to be something
different than they are to get access to
Victory so you know it's that's a
no-brainer
um so it really comes down to a question
of do the SMP just not care about
women's safeguarding and it would seem
that they're willing to sacrifice some
women they'll you know this this kind of
legislation will result in some sexual
assaults so then it comes down to well
how many sexual assaults are the s p
prepared to accept as collateral and
that's really what that's what the
feminists have been arguing that's what
they've been saying but Nicholas
sturgeon has I mean she's already said
that they these arguments have no merit
she's already said with she's just
dismissing them she's not going to
listen to them and now they've actually
just railroaded it through and they're
just uh they've proven it so it's a I
think it's a problem with the s p i mean
the s p think they're being really
Progressive on almost every issue and
they're actually an incredibly
regressive party in in almost every
respect I mean they push through their
uh hate speech bill which is one of the
most Draconian uh authoritarian pieces
of legislation we've ever seen in the UK
where you can be prosecuted for stuff
you say in your own home uh where you
can be prosecuted uh for for jokes for
there's a section on the public
performance of a play so we can put on a
play and get if we put on a play of
trigonometry of our conversation now has
dramatized that I mean that would be
ahead correct yeah I mean it wouldn't be
a good
players yeah but they could process if
that was at the Edinburgh Fringe like
they could prosecute that you know this
is just unbelievable stuff and so I
think I think the problem is that the s
p have too much power because there's no
the Tories and labor they have nothing
in Scotland there's no second party to
hold them to account you know it's it's
it's like if if you know if if some if
some powerful figure is left unchecked
and is only surrounded by sycophants you
know where that goes you know so
I don't know what they're going to do
about that I mean the feminists are
saying they're going to keep protesting
and keep making their point but while
while people just keep keep dismissing
these concerns as anti-trans or hateful
which is just not the case I'm not
saying there aren't hateful anti-trans
people out there but they're not the
people who are who are protesting
outside of Hollywood they're not the
people who are saying we have these
legitimate concerns
um these are just people who are being
monstered for trying to make a
completely Fair Point about safeguarding
you know but also as well you know the
focus and the obsession we now have with
lgbtqia plus whatever it is yeah we were
we it felt like we reached this peak of
Tolerance where got to the stage the
stone it was like I don't care who you
know I don't care what you do in the
privacy of the of your own home you know
it doesn't matter but now it's like it's
almost become a well it's literally
become a badge of Pride and Qatar was a
very good example of this yeah exactly
did you see the other day the the
rainbow flag there's a new addition to
the rainbow flag there's always a new
[ __ ] Edition I mean it's so what's
the newest well it's a red umbrella
which is for sex workers rights so you
have so obviously we've got the Chevrons
with the Trans colors and the black
stripe and the brown striper racial
inclusivity and the intersex Circle and
now you've got the [ __ ] uh sex worker
umbrella there you can barely now see
the rainbow because there's so much [ __ ]
on the planet right and this and
obviously people are saying well
actually looking at that now this looks
kind of homophobic because you've just
crowded a gay pride flag with lots of
other symbols so we can't even see the
gay bit anymore
um it's a real problem and look and look
by the way I'm obviously we're having a
light-hearted discussion but it's
something I've been aware of and I'm
sure you're aware of as well which is
among young people acceptance of LGBT
blah blah blah is going down yeah of
course and that's because they're
looking at this [ __ ] and going what the
[ __ ] is this yeah I just I just wanted
to treat everybody equally well now I'm
have I have and anyway racial what does
that have to do with nothing to do the
whole the rainbow flag I mean I've got
to stand a bit about this because the
rainbow flag was about Unity it was
about the rainbow symbol meant unity and
Harmony it was not a literal
representation of the skin colors that
are acceptable in the gay community
right and so the idea that you have to
add different racial it's so mental it's
so and it makes us look like idiots it
makes the gays look pathetic and I don't
like that okay it's what you said like
we we were at a point where but no one
cared no one cared how you identified or
or who you slept with or whether you
wanted to be called he or she or no one
I mean I don't remember anyone knowing
anyone who ever had a problem with any
of that now I know a lot the gay people
who won't use pronouns that people
prefer on a matter of principle well
that would they no one ever cared about
it before but now they do because now
they're being told to use pronouns that
are either invented like toy and toy
self or cat and cat gender and and she
and sure and and they as singular and
people aren't going to do that they're
not going to stop [ __ ] with the
language
um to satisfy someone else's ego which
is effectively what it is
um and also you see all this crazy stuff
you remember that Canadian teacher with
the massive boobs I love that story yes
I mean well didn't we discuss it I think
a lot of people have thought it was a
troll it is a troll but it's not oh well
it looks like he's not a troll so it's a
story out of South Park there was that
old episode of South Park where Mr
Garrison wants to be able to sue the
school for homophobia to make money so
he brings his [ __ ] boyfriend in with
like you know anal beads or whatever and
and and ball gags and all the rest of it
and uh and of course the school is all
really tolerant and this is your this is
who you are it's fine he's and he's he's
gutted because they won't let him he
wants to sue them yeah and they thought
this was a similar thing this guy goes
into this school in Canada woodwork
teacher by the way so you know there is
a health and safety issue here because
he's got these massive prosthetic
breasts that are like distended others
that that go even below his waist
they're absolutely huge and there's even
footage of him using an electric saw
with these rather cumbersome pendulous
items but it's fetish gear you know this
isn't who he is they just it's it's what
he enjoys it's a message right it's and
and so now they're saying that the kids
in the school who are secretly filming
or taking pictures they'll be expelled
for doing that that news broke this week
so the school is really clamping down on
this but why not just say we support our
teachers our members of Staff right to
identify however they want but you can't
wear fetish gear to work why not just
say that it's uncontroversial right but
then it's really problematic Now isn't
it even just to refer to it as fetish
gear which is fetish game well I know it
is obviously is and like we and that's
the thing that's really happened this
year I think overall is the sort of
introduction of sexual like
hypersexualization into into the gay
rights movement and all the rest of it
the Kink stuff at Pride yeah every time
I open Twitter there's some drag queen
shaking her ass in front of a
five-year-old right or his ass or
whatever like or drag drag isn't trans
so it's a man yeah you know basically
twerking in front of a three-year-old or
teaching a three-year-old to twerk for
tips I mean it's it's Grim it's really
it's really good and what it does is it
re resuscitates this ancient homophobic
Trope which yoked gay people with
pedophiles and that was something that
gay people fought to sort of get away
from and now they're doing this stuff
it's it's it's it's really bad for gay
rights it's it's and like it's not there
is some room for nuance here and so far
as a drag queen reading a story to a
bunch of kids in a library in a
non-sexualized way I don't like that's
fun it's weird I think it's weird
because drag for me is a sexualized
genre and part of the fun of drag is how
edgy it is and how how far it pushes the
boundaries if you want to sanitize that
I don't think you're a great drag artist
I think you're a boring drag artist and
and so I don't know why you'd want to
sanitize your art to do that but okay I
can accept the drag performers they're
quite Lively they're quite declamatory
they would be able to do a good job I
think of a story but part of the problem
is either the stories they choose are
basically indoctrination are basically
sort of ideological indoctrination
um or they put on a performance that is
inappropriately sexual now in both of
those cases I think to stop doing that
you know
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door that is good but I wasn't
talking about their locals I was talking
about our community on locals you mean
the one where you get phenomenal behind
the scenes content when you thank you
when you get to wasp incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson we're at Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes footage of our trip to
America where we met a whole host of
incredible guests and gave ourselves
terminal indigestion we're also starting
to do monthly giveaways for locals only
the first one will be signed copies of
Andrew door's new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share memes have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
and also the word queer is just being
by everybody I mean straight now
basically like you see I've seen
pictures of like celebrity couples and
we are an out queer couple I'm like
you're a straight couple you're a man
you're a woman you're [ __ ] that's
straight that's not and you don't get to
sort of grab that phrase and say we're
oppressed I mean that's really what it
is it's people identifying themselves
into oppressed groups because there's a
kind of Glamor or Sheen around being
oppressed why isn't it better not to be
oppressed why why would you say well not
anymore but this you you I mean you know
this you've put your finger on it it is
not better to not be oppressed it is
much better to be oppressed we covered a
story on one of our raw shows a few days
ago uh where there's a woman who is a a
woman of color uh and she got a job at
the BBC due to some kind of diversity
scheme yeah right her dad owns a Premier
League Football Club
wow she's the daughter of a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire yeah and
we always forget but it is better to be
oppressed yeah well this is because
you're not actually oppressed anymore
you're just getting bonus point points
for being brown or black or lesbian or
gay or whatever is that's why it's
better to be bisexual even if you're
just straight or non-binary even if you
just CIS or whatever but that's also why
people are obsessed with Meghan Markle
because she is an actual princess
complaining about being oppressed yeah
and people are sick of it but no you're
right you hit it it's it's uh you know
whenever the BBC and bodies like that
push these diversity schemes and said we
need a quota for a certain number of
racial groups what mostly happen is Posh
people of color got the jobs right
people who didn't need a leg up people
who weren't depressed and so the class
issue is a big thing as you know we've
spoken about this many times for me
unless you are concerned about class
issues uh put pushing Working Class
People up Social Mobility economic
inequality and trying to redress that if
you're not interested in those things I
don't think you're left-wing in any
meaningful sense so the whole
identitarian movement the whole lgbtqia
nonsense uh the critical race Theory
nonsense all of all of this stuff is
essentially an upper middle class
Pursuit it has got nothing to do with
being left-wing at all I would argue
it's more right-wing actually because
it's concerned with Posh people and
their interests Andrew why is it
acceptable for a straight person to
describe themselves as queer yeah but if
a person identifies as being black and
if they're white or of A different race
that is somehow unacceptable I don't
understand what the difference is well
that exact question was posed by Richard
Dawkins this year on Twitter I think
near the start of the year and uh he had
an award taken away from him even it was
a humanist award
what's hilarious is he actually said I
don't remember getting that um
he did what scientists often do which is
pose a hypothetical he even ended the
hypothetical with the word discuss he
basically said why is it that when uh
when a a man identifies as a woman they
are universally celebrated but when
Rachel dolezal identifies as black she
is universally condemned disgust it's a
legitimate question it's the question
you just asked in fact you're very much
On a par with Dawkins I feel interested
thank you very much
um
nothing that could take from you third
place at the Hackney Empire yes and your
cycling proficiency tester I can't ride
a bike mate sorry oh well I'm wrong
about that
um so yeah it's a good question to ask
like what why it but that is probably
the end point isn't it and there were
intimations of it you remember the
Rachel dollars I think they were
Intimates when you know you had
journalists on CNN and things saying
well maybe you can identify as black and
that did get shut down quite quickly but
I think we'll go there eventually as
well I think that's that's obviously
look did you see the thing about the
Norwegian interview there was no
interview on Norwegian TV about four or
five months ago a man an able-bodied man
who identifies as a disabled woman in a
wheelchair doesn't need the wheelchair
but identifies as having to have the
wheelchair and they gave him a really
sympathetic interview about his truth
and and you just want to say just stand
up you don't need like this is really
offensive to just roll on in and say
well I've always won he said I've always
felt that I wanted to be a woman who
couldn't feel anything from the waist
down but you're not you're a bloke you
can jump around like it's and so that's
to why what you're right why not race
the guy wasn't there that Peter pilot
tried to get out of it by saying well he
identified as a child you know that that
there was that guy it's a logical end
point of all these bollocks it's like if
you can identify as anything and look
sitting in that chair only a few days
ago was Ollie London ah now is Ollie
London trolling uh no he just got a bit
carried away okay his words and he's
seen the light he identified as Korean
yeah he identified as Korea and then he
identified as a woman he had a [ __ ] ton
of surgery and then he realized this was
not helping so what's he now he's just a
man who's had a lot of surgery who wants
to sort of you know explain to people
that he went down the wrong path and
they shouldn't follow him well I
remember talking to him last year on on
GB news not it wasn't in a direct
interview I was just involved in the
chat and he struck me as just a bit uh
just a bit mad a little bit mad you know
I think if you have a [ __ ] ton of
surgery to try and make yourself career
and you probably are in that moment but
he's actually very sensible now well he
didn't seem unpleasant he's one of them
no no he seemed like a nice guy it was a
bit Posh and mad he's a lovely guy and
if anyone hasn't seen that interview
they should go and watch it because it
you just see the you know sometimes
people and the thing that he said to us
that
see it's not going to be a great
Revelation to people watching this
because it's obvious but he said well
Society tells you now you can identify
as anything yeah why can't I be Korean
and there's there's a logic to that if
you look around if you spend most of
your time on social media if you're a
young person who who maybe doesn't have
a huge amount of experience with the
real world you you haven't had the
opportunity to see yourself make
mistakes and go well sometimes you
believe things and then you realize they
were wrong yeah you look around and you
go well why why can't I identify for
sure and actually and that's the danger
of all of the [ __ ] is my point there's a
point where to an extent you can like I
think nationality is very complicated I
think ngozi Palani did being descended
from African people I think she has a
right to identify with that country but
there's a grain there's a truth to that
she's not even from Africa she's not but
she you know it's like I speak to him I
was in New York the other week and I was
speaking to American guy and he was
talking about his Scottish great
grandfather but he was describing
himself as Scottish and although that's
a bit alien to us I think In America
which is a nation of immigrants where
you know I don't think that's a lie and
I actually think it's legitimate I think
you could there is an element of
personal choice because we're all
Mongols from all sorts of places I think
your identity into the nationality that
is a bit malleable I think when it comes
to gender
you know if I genuinely felt that I'm so
uncomfortable with being male that I
have to present and identify as FEMA I
think that should be respected I don't
have it I really don't have a problem
with that but when it comes down to
denial of complete facts so for instance
could I say I'm Nigerian I have
absolutely no connection
but but I don't have that should be a
Christmas special
come out dresses are Nigeria I I really
welcome to Free Speech Nation it's so
easy to kill your career isn't it it's
so easy
you've got to do it for the troll mate I
mean
wow you don't even do blackface just
gotta identify as an idea I don't make
any effort at all I'm just like exactly
as I am yeah that's just my truth yeah
you see now that then that becomes in
the Realms of satire of ridiculousness
you know and I think and I think um but
similarly that's why people always had a
tolerance for people identifying as the
opposite sex because we understood
gender dysphoria as a concept right but
we don't have to for someone identifying
as a cat which some people now are doing
I mean very few I should say
um but but we don't have to honor to
that because it's so divorced from
reality that at some point you have to
say that is not the truth but even when
it comes to trans identification right
trans people aren't saying they are
literally the opposite sex or I know
some are but but most trans people know
that they're not yeah and they accept
that and they will make that point it's
about feeling comfortable with the way
you present that's fine and so I think
there is room for some sort of nuance
here but but look you're right some of
the identification points race racial
identification points it's it's and
actually it identifying as a different
race makes more sense than identifying
as a different sex because there are
only two Sexes and no human being has
ever changed sex but racially we're all
the same like race there is there is
there is a strong argument regarding
race as a social construct which I
actually get on board with in fact it's
you know ever since they sort of decoded
our DNA we realize we're all the same
well you know they're just they're just
disintended at any tangible difference
so there's more of a case for doing that
and yet that's the thing that's
demonized it's interesting well a lot of
this is because of social media yeah and
and let's talk about Twitter for a
moment because yeah Twitter has been in
many ways one of the one of the things
that's helped to create this it's one of
the catalysts behind all this nonsense
but it's been a very interesting year
for Twitter hasn't it absolutely yeah I
mean it's I think thank God for Elon
Musk I think it's really I'm not saying
he's perfect and you know and that he
hasn't made some strategic blunders
which he had
but my God I mean what a revolution you
know so many people whose accounts have
been nuked For No Good Reason Just for
having the wrong opinion they're back on
the channel there's some more I'd like
to see back on like Graeme Linehan and
people like that
um hopefully that eventually we'll get
to that point but what Elon Musk was
trying to do was say look we're going to
have any all and any opinions and
discussions can be had you know and
that's a that's a good thing and we're
not just gonna sense I mean he's gonna
he's going to Nuke accounts to break the
law he's already kicked off a lot of
accounts that have been child
trafficking and peddling in child
pornography well good right because I
don't think illegal activity should be
going on on the channel but I think any
speech that it should be allowed even if
it's offensive speech and I think that's
that's a positive step well I agree with
you that I'm glad that he's taken over I
don't think he's is as consistent on
these issues as anyone would want and
frankly he's been quite inconsistent
yeah and I think he knows it yeah well
he does and this is why you know the
people I've always looked with some
skepticism of people who claim to be
free speech absolutist because you may
may be in theory but when it comes down
to practice when you have to run a
platform like Twitter you rapidly find
out that people aren't no one is a free
speech absolutely I mean I think I am
and suppose if I were running Twitter I
would say here's I don't need a
moderation Council I don't need anyone
moderating this what I would have is
you've got a block button if you don't
want to read something block it block
the person that's it's a user-based
thing and that that solves all your
problems obviously there's a legal
content you delete it because you that's
illegal yourself if you're because
that's why you need a moderation account
so that's to decide whether something's
illegal or not well the law does that
perfectly sufficiently but I knew oh
that's why you have you need you need
people to implement the law in other
words but that's not quite the same as a
moderation Council the moderation
council is saying what is acceptable for
our platform I just say don't yeah let
anyone say anything I I I know what you
mean but
that the internet of the early days yeah
which was free that's not coming back I
know I'm sure it's not going to happen I
know it's not they're just they're not
going to let you do that even if you own
the company I'm not going to own the
company constantly it's not going to
happen this is not I don't have 44
billion dollars
but you weren't flash for cash I didn't
go fast for cash there's not much cash
in there it's mad but Andrew let's talk
about the Twitter files because you and
I I think in this country have been at
the Forefront of the people going this
is quite important yeah and no one's
[ __ ] talking about it Madness the
media I don't understand we have had in
the last few days Revelations that the
FBI had the New York uh post the laptop
that was the source of the New York Post
story about Hunter Biden they sat on it
and then they deceived Twitter unlikely
Facebook into thinking that it was
Russian disinformation yeah this is
Watergate level yeah selection
interference by the FBI of course right
hugely that seems to me quite important
the BBC the times even the telegraph the
the guy I mean the guardian obviously
haven't covered it they and this isn't
to say by the way that they don't think
Twitter is important because they cover
Elon musk's polls every day yeah but
they won't tell us anything about that
they won't tell them the public
the reading public anything about that
and I literally feel myself becoming
radicalized on a daily basis there's
another bit of Revelation that is not
being covered isn't it insane and uh I I
have to say GB news has covered it well
you've covered it I've covered it over
the last three weeks I've been covering
from day one because I and and I've been
particularly I share your view I've been
completely I I don't understand why this
isn't Front Page News everywhere right
and it should have been from day one
look the fact and and the way
journalists have been saying this oh
this is a nothing Burger a phrase I
hadn't heard before and I hate it and
they all now say it they all say they're
all saying the same phrases why are you
doing PR for the world's richest man and
they all use that phrase it's like
they're all robots saying the same
things it's bizarre they're not doing
any thinking for themselves but the idea
that you wouldn't cover this no matter
what your political view I don't
understand like why why wouldn't you be
interested that and they say things like
why do you care so much about Hunter by
about Hunter Biden's dick about nudes I
don't care uh I haven't seen it maybe I
would care
um I don't care about that stuff I care
about the fact that politicians and the
social media Tech Giant colluded to
suppress a news story they got to decide
what the public should read that's what
I can in the run-up to an election about
a story that was potentially
unflattering for one of the candidates
that's what I care about I couldn't give
a damn about the substance of the story
I really cover up yeah to cover up
that's the story and you know the other
stuff that the Twitter files have you
know the fact that they knew the
executives knew they had no grounds for
suppressing this story and they openly
said that to each other they effectively
were saying how can we get away with it
you know same with the Trump thing they
they knew that they had no grounds to to
to ban Trump from the past and arguably
in some way I mean obviously the hunter
Biden thing is is big in terms of
electoral interference but I think as a
structural issue Shadow Banning people
like Jay battachary yeah exactly you're
hiding things from the public because
you've decided to put your thumb on the
scales and the thing is you don't have
the expertise
so the idea that they that suddenly a
few 20-something uh you know gen Zeds at
Twitter are World leading
epidemiologists is incredible to me they
had absolutely no right well they sort
of prevented his tweets from being
Amplified yeah right yeah trending Etc
and we have evidence and I don't mean
like a conspiracy theory we have a video
that we did with Peter Hitchens early in
the lockdown yeah which we have direct
evidence was being Shadow banned by
YouTube and Google you could not find it
on Google and you could not find it in
the search on YouTube and if you had to
go to the link to watch it isn't it
interesting that these journalists and
all these people for years were saying
firstly oh it's Twitter it's a private
company they can do what they want I had
a lot of uh people saying to me um well
this isn't true conservatives aren't
being censored you've got no evidence
for it where are those people now well
now we do the evidence is absolutely
plain in black and white and they're
just so they're just going to ignore it
no no they don't just ignore it they say
oh we knew this already well then like
the same people who said it's not
happening are now saying well we knew
this well either they were lying then or
they're lying now and that's just
bizarre like for me if I put my neck out
there and said there's no evidence for
that so I'm not going to believe it and
then I see the evidence I'll come out
and say I was wrong and I accept that
I'm like why why can't they do that
that's what I don't understand and also
as you say this thing about the media
ignoring it the BBC covering it not one
iota is is absolutely unforgivable and
shocking that's they are in dereliction
of their journalistic Duty they're quite
clearly I mean this is this is a huge
story no matter which way you sit
politically it would be just as big if
the tables were turned if it were the
case that it were you know I mean look
Trump's team were trying to get tweets
censored right the document they just
weren't doing it yeah because they hated
Trump right so it's not as big a story
it's not as big a story right it's as
big as it's a big story that that the
Democrats were doing it because they
actually got those things implemented on
a huge scale that's why that's more of a
story but I also care Trump's team had
no right to be trying to get tweets
deleted I'd care about that as well and
if the tables were turned entirely and
it was mostly the Republicans who had
been doing this I'd be making the same
noise about it so why so it's got
nothing to do with politics well think
about this Andrew Francis had just
finished this and let you there you go
for it
the The crucial story that would make
your journalistic career as a left-wing
journalist 20 years ago yeah would be
exposing collusion between government
and the other right yeah that's what
that would be the great scoop yeah
exposing the establishment corruption
between politicians and the intelligence
people and big Tech big corporations
that's that's the left-wing journalistic
natural Target isn't it right the
collusion between big corporates big
government and big intelligence that's
what it was it was and they are now all
on board with this which goes back to
what I was saying earlier about how this
is not a left-wing movie no right so
this is not the same as Occupy Wall
Street or anything like that that the
fact that
self-declared leftists are in bed with
the corporate and political class means
they are no longer leftists frankly and
we should stop calling them left wing as
far as I can see they can carry on doing
that they want but they're not we had an
interview with Sam Harris which went
viral in which he he made a number of
outrageous statements but basically his
argument was that he didn't care because
the ends justify the means isn't this
but just writ large amongst our entire
media political class
Etc it's exactly that it's this idea
that you will excuse any kind of poor
Behavior as long as it's from your own
tribe I just think it's I think while
you and I are all similar in this we
don't have a tribe and that's the way to
be I think like just just
don't don't because otherwise if you
align yourself with one way of thinking
one ideology one group it means you you
are literally Outsourcing your thinking
to someone else and you're saying I will
never think for myself again you I mean
you may as well kill yourself at that
point what's the point but seriously
what's the point in being alive if
you're just going to say someone else do
my thinking for me you know priest you
tell me what to think about the world I
mean why would you do that to yourself
but these are intelligent people these
are ivy league graduates it doesn't
matter I mean people people are Ivy
League schools can be really stupid
we've seen them and particularly now
that so many higher education
institutions are effectively just
churning out ideological nonsense and
just attempting to train people to think
a certain way they're not really
universities anymore just as the
activists aren't really left-wing
anymore these universities aren't
University are there any Universities in
name as far as I can see and what
another interesting point about the
entire story was a lot of the time Jack
Dorsey didn't even know it was going on
no I know yeah it's weird isn't it
whether that was deliberate by the way
we don't know yeah that may have been
deliberate it's he may have put himself
on that position so that he could go to
Congress because he's quite possibly
lied to Congress under oath really yeah
it's quite possible that that is what
happened now it may be the case that he
had plausible deniability about knowing
right right because he said to Congress
they don't Shadow ban people
yes but they yeah okay but the way
around that is that they didn't call it
Shadow money they call it visibility
filtering yes which is you know which is
I mean I made the point on my show you
know this was like when the CIA used to
do enhanced interrogation yeah which
means they could say we've never
tortured anyone we've just interrogated
them in an enhanced way which means
sticking pins in their nails or whatever
they didn't do that but they did they
did some pretty nasty stuff and and you
know just this is something that
authoritarians always do and they've
always done it they've just changed the
words to describe the horrible things
they're doing you know it's it's it's
it's like um an example I've given
before was a was um there's a bit in one
of salmon rushdie's essays where he
talks about watching a general in the
Vietnam War talking about we have
achieved a hundred percent mortality
response what he means by that is we've
killed everyone and just by sanitizing
it and saying this chilling phrase that
sort of gets around the truth uh and
this is the core belief of all of these
identitarian activists that if we could
just change the way that the words and
the definitions of words it means we can
make anything palatable right so you
know even down to you know a therapist
talking to a child who might be confused
about their gender suddenly you call
that trans conversion therapy and and
suddenly becomes an evil horrible thing
that you mustn't do whereas actually
it's a moral good that you were trying
to do they invert everything so moral
Goods become evil and vice versa right
so and I find it it's got to be the
first sign of something creeping into
the authoritarianism when they start
changing definitions and forcing you to
accept their definitions and that's the
thing we've got to be really wary of so
visibility filtering no it's Shadow
Banning and they they knew what we all
meant by Shadow Banning because they
once used the phrase in the same way
it's it's it's trickery chicanery it's
it's it might end up as you say with
criminal charge but I mean even Elon
Musk said Twitter is a crime scene
that's how he described it
have a website or do you plan to have a
website because if you do then easy DNS
is a company for you easy DNS is the
perfect domain name registrar provider
and web host for you they have a track
record of standing up for their clients
whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
techno technology privacy and censorship
and Andrew you mentioned uh salmon Rusty
yeah and I think this year that was not
the only incident uh with him being did
Sir David Amos happen this year as well
I I think
and and that the thing that I found
particularly shocking in the sir David
Ames case it was a British MP who was
stabbed to death by a Jihadi
um was the response from our political
class incredible do you remember what
happened they used the murder to um
promote their own ideological agenda
they were all saying we need to clamp
down on the line yeah trolls why don't
we just clamp down on jihadi's stabbing
people could we do that well because
that would be to address the actual
issue right no there was no evidence to
suggest that anything to do with this
crime had come about due to online
trolls none it's just MPS didn't like
being insulted online and they used this
they said they were prepared to use this
as to hook on to to I mean it's it's so
morally repugnant it just is it's it's
and it's an absolute barefaced refusal
to address the problem of Islamic
extremism but because to do so uh you
well it's the grooming gang situation
all over again you expose yourself to
the accusation of racism but you know it
makes no sense at all because of course
some of the most obvious victims of this
form of extremism are Muslims so this is
something that we have to address but
you're right there's that the salmon
Rusty thing you know I I found just
absolutely horrific obviously not just
because of the attack but the response
to the attack and you know that who's
that idiot at the independent Sean
O'Grady is his name something Grady I
think they're all idiots yeah yeah this
is a real I mean he and he wrote many
years ago about how um he would burn a
copy of the satanic versus If he if he
had it I mean there's all this sort of
apologism for the worst kind of
authoritarianism uh that you that you
can possibly have and that why wasn't
there just Universal condemnation this
happened because he wrote a book
you know uh that's it and and I think
it's because we failed at the time 1988
1989 was it when the Centennial verses
came out we sort of capitulated there
were debates on TV people started saying
I mean I was seven at the time so I'm
probably not responsible I'm not
responsible either but but I know I was
joking but there were people saying well
maybe he shouldn't have written a book I
remember when I was at school when it
happened I remember one of my teachers
my Christian theology teacher saying
yeah but you know if you write a book
insulting someone's religion you get
what you deserve and you know so
but but
um
the what astonishment I even knew at the
time yeah even as a kid that that was
wrong to say to victim blame to use the
current parlance right to say that you
can't you know the idea that for start
they hadn't read the book you know and
it is a brilliant book so let's just get
that out of the way
um but this sort of attack reminds us
that actually could the Satanic Verses
be published today would anyone even
dare write this today and the reason
they weren't is because we failed from
1988 right through to now even with
Charlie hebdo when that happened we
failed to come out in to get what we did
for like five minutes and say we condemn
this but actually no the media should
have put those pictures everywhere you
know everyone should be saying this is
not right you shouldn't
it's something I get particularly uh
wound up about because because the idea
that an artist could be attacked or
killed for for their art is it's kind of
like to me a complete repudiation of
civilization and everything
achieved and Samuel Rashi said this
himself he wrote a really brilliant
Memoir called Joseph Anton Joseph Anton
being the pseudonym that he used when he
was in hiding and in this Memoir he
recalls seeing on the streets of
Bradford the images of his book being
burned it wasn't just burnt it was
crucified then immolated it was nailed
to a piece of wood and then it was set
on fire and he said that visual image
felt him like that the achievement of
the Enlightenment was somehow temporary
or reversible
and it's true the image of a burning
book it chills us not because the book
The book's replaceable it's just a thing
but because it reminds us of those path
news reels of Goebbels in the open Platz
or the Babel Platts as it's now called
in Berlin uh casually tossing books onto
the fire we think of we we think of
Fahrenheit 451 you know these things
matter to us because of what it
represents and the idea that activists
now you see a kind of collision between
uh Ultra conservative religious
extremists and identitarian leftist
activists who will happily burn we
talked about it didn't we the uh the
flame purification ceremony in Canada
where school boards burnt books because
they had problematic representations uh
or where activists over here burn copies
of Harry Potter and they don't think
that this has some kind of historical
resonance and they don't see how
authoritarian that act is and how
unforgivable that act is and this is why
I get bothered by just stop oil
vandalizing great works of art such as
the sunflowers by Vincent van Gogh and
yes you could say there's a plastic
there's a you know glass the thing isn't
being damaged but the symbolism of that
the complete negation of of human
civilization on artistic achievement
that is so wrapped up in that movement
the complete mistrust of humanity the
degradation of humanity that that's it
that to attack that Masterpiece tells us
all you need to know about these
people's mindsets and how little they
care for all of the achievements of
humankind sorry that was a rant and a
welcome one yeah it just it winds me up
as you can tell yeah very well put but I
think there's something else more basic
going on here which is the cowardice of
our Elites the people should stand up
and should condemn who have the
platforms they don't do it so on on the
one hand I have some sympathy
it is quite scary when the people you're
condemning have a habit of beheading
people
so I get that that is a deterrent right
I think that is from a human level I
completely understand that but when
you're talking about a whole media class
or a whole political class failing to
address that issue you know the safety
in numbers as well you know if the
politicians have a responsibility to
address that issue
um so you know
I understand why people don't want to
mock or attack a religion when there's a
tiny minority of that religion who will
take action into their own hands I get
that but that doesn't mean that we as a
society shouldn't be having these
conversations or that it's forgivable to
leave those girls to be raped and abused
just because we don't want to be accused
of being racist or indeed at the
Manchester Arena bombing where the man
was not intercepted because people were
afraid of being called racist you know
this isn't good enough yeah no and it's
also badly grammar school with the
unions oh that was incredible yeah but
notice that again in Batley uh these are
the Muslim protesters who want to who
one of the teachers that showed a
cartoon of the Prophet Muhammad and they
wanted to but they used the language of
the intersectional woke they said we we
felt unsafe and the students are unsafe
now and this is a safeguarding issue see
they borrow from each other the
similarities shouldn't surprise us
because they're although they're not
morally comparable they are both
authoritarian branches of different
kinds which shouldn't surprise us that
they do this and again I should point
out Batley grammar school protesters
they weren't attacking anyone uh they
didn't threaten anyone but the teacher
did get death threats from other
quarters yeah we had this year the lady
of Heaven the film where cineworld
capitulated so you have these protesters
outside these Cinemas and I have support
peaceful protest they should be able to
do that
um I had an Imam on my show debating
this very topic I think they should be
allowed to express their displeasure
with the film but cineworld should not
capitulate and shut down a film made by
Muslims by the way it was just made by
the wrong type of Muslims right so
that's what bothers me about it there
was no individual risk for cineworld
to not show this film you know that
that's not but you say that I don't know
if that's true I mean we don't know if
that's true what if they didn't shut
down the film The protest continued and
eventually the the manager of the cinema
gets stabbed I mean that's right that's
what he's scared of isn't it it's a
possibility but Andrew since we've got
serious I suppose the question I've been
thinking about over the course of the
last year is we talk about all these
cultural silliness and and I think it's
important I don't I don't trivialize it
um but one of the things that I think
has happened in the last kind of 20
years is the world that we lived in
before where uh you know the economy was
doing quite well yeah and everything was
quite comfortable and there weren't
really that you know there was no Wars
going on of major significance that
affected us yeah in the in the West
that world is slowly ending the economy
is absolutely [ __ ] uh there's a war
that broke out in Europe we had a
pandemic
everyone in their dog is on strike at
the moment in this country
do you think that given that we've got
really tough times ahead I'm I'm
unfortunately convinced that that is in
the real world that is going to be the
case do you think we will look back at
this year and the last few years and
think we got distracted from serious
things or do you think this craziness is
just going to run and run it's a really
good question but I think it's
I think the Crux of it was 2020 I think
it was the summer of 2020 I think that's
where the culture War exploded into the
mainstream and I don't think that can
now be ignored as you know I've always
said and argued that the culture war is
key issue because it wins and loses
elections yes it determines the course
of history uh it's something that we
ignore in our Peril and I I'm very
mistrustful for people to say it's a
distraction from other issues because
you can care about more than one issue
but also people who say that they
effectively what usually what it is is
they agree with the culture Warriors
stance and so they don't want criticism
of their of their precious ideology
that's normally what it is of course
these things are all important and and
you don't just ignore one important
thing because there's something that
might be slightly more important you
don't do that you address various things
particularly if you're in politics now
what Ron DeSantis has really got right
is that he has prioritized the economy
and things such as covid and getting the
getting getting people back to schools
getting people back to work and actually
running
his area of Florida in a an efficient
way but he also hasn't neglected
cultural issues and has been talking
about how we need to tackle critical
race theory in schools the racial
division that it engenders uh gender
identity ideology and the the problems
that that causes for gay people and for
women and children he does address all
of those stuff but he also handles all
the other things so I think for a
politician to just focus solely on
cultural issues is a nonsense because we
have all of these economic issues to
deal with and to prioritize but by the
same token a a government that ignores
culturalism or issues or Stokes them is
also making matters worse and the Tory
party is hugely to blame I mean the
culture War has escalated in this
country since 2012 roughly and the
Tories have been in charge all of that
time and they've made it well the civil
service is now out of control
completely captured that's the Machinery
of government right there and no one's
doing anything about it the NHS
completely captured and the Tories are
nowhere to be seen it's like they just
don't care about this stuff or they
don't understand it uh if they were
genuinely conservative they would do
something about it and you don't even
have to be conservative if you were
genuinely left wing you would do
something about it or if you were
generally liberal you'd do something
right exactly there is no excuse for
labor and the Tories and for that matter
the lib Dems not to prioritize
completely quashing this culture War and
the culture Warriors that fight it so
why haven't they
I don't think they get it I don't think
they I don't think they understand what
the implications are I think they're
starting to with Tavistock I think maybe
now they're starting to see that
um I think you get the egregious stuff
like the American schools segregating
children by skin color after you know
for extracurricular activities and stuff
and we can all laugh at that although
it's really [ __ ] horrible of course
like it's so we should but it has ever
been a precedent where that has gone
badly or what racial segregation exactly
good point good point
um but it's interesting you know Eric
Kaufman recently did a study about the
extent to which critical race Theory and
gender identity ideology which are
basically the two tines of the same
Pitchfork uh they the extent to which
that is now the norm in schools in the
UK most children encounter both most
children are taught in one way or
another both of these things uh that
don't divide us did many many Freedom of
Information requests to schools and
councils and found the same thing uh
We've we've got evidence we've seen the
Brighton council's anti-racist school
strategy which is a direct template of
critical race Theory being implemented
so the the argument this really isn't
happening is a lie and we now have the
evidence for that um so why then does
not the education secretary step in why
does not the health secretary step in
why don't you know why when you have an
official NHS policy of accommodating
patients by gender identity rather than
sex and also in addition to that having
an official NHS policy whereby if a
biological woman complains because
there's a biological male on her Ward
she is to be told you are wrong there
are no there are no men here
that is official NHS policy is to
Gaslight women
um even to the extent when there was a
sexual assault on a ward the police came
to investigate and the police were told
it couldn't have happened because there
was no man on that Ward right this is
really serious and at what point does
the government say actually we're gonna
we're gonna do something about it for
ages Boris Johnson talked about a war on
woke I don't think he even knows what
woke means no and I don't think he even
knows that the Tories are woke I don't
think he gets that
um so until so in other words the
culture War to answer your question
hugely important because it has massive
effects on people's lives it's also a
massive waste of money the amount that
is spent on diversity and equity and
inclusion training uh which money That
Could by the way be better placed in
terms of our economic uh deprivation
um but to not address that is is is
completely myopic in my view I think you
can do both and you can do both
effectively you just have to firstly you
have to take the effort to understand it
and then you have to implement some
policies that will address it
um this is I mean the reason I wrote my
book is because I feel people don't
understand the problems and the whole
book is about trying to explain the
problems you know I'm not saying Tori
should buy my book but yeah they should
they should they should you know just
just make the effort to understand the
problem and then resolve the problem I
suppose is what I'm saying
so we're coming to the end of the
interview and it was meant to be a
light-hearted positive it was too
serious no I always don't know but it's
great but it's great it started
lighthearted we did a bit of serious
we'll finish on a knob game everybody's
happy right I always do this they don't
know like I had this the other way
it's not a podcast in American I got
loads of comments like you're too
serious I'm like yeah maybe but no it's
been great but let's focus let's focus
on something positive oh can we see the
green shoots of recovery Andrew in terms
of common sense in terms of fighting
back against the nonsense come on give
me something uh yeah I don't really I
don't really like the phrase common
sense because it implies that there's a
kind of there's just something we all
know I get what you're driving at yeah
um you know do we get to do we come back
there are signs okay yeah there are
signs that people are it doesn't believe
me I've done my best I'm going to be
positive here okay no Andrew you don't
have to be positive because I think what
people actually want to hear is what you
really think yeah yeah but but what I
really think of course you can come up
with a positive example but what do you
think but what are you optimistic for
the future what I think is that I am I
am both optimistic and pessimistic and
that's why I'm trying to formulate this
accurately
well some days I'm really positive I
think wow we're winning this yeah and
some days I think
we're absolutely not because every time
there is a victory there's like 12
setbacks you know and like for instance
okay here's one positive thing
and it's to do with the young it's to do
with the fact that whenever I go and
talk on universities the young people
the students always really impress me
always I've never been and maybe it's
because I'm I'm appearing and therefore
the kind of people who would come along
are unlikely to be antagonistic but then
you know
you know I I gave a talk recently at
Gumball and keys College in Cambridge
and it was the week after Helen Joyce
had been on and at the same college and
she'd had people beating drums and air
horns and whatever and students and and
so I spoke to the students a lot of the
students had come to my talk as well I
didn't get any protests or anything
because I was talking about John Milton
and it would be really weird when people
got really upset about the author of
Paradise Lost That would be bizarre um
but I was but but I was talking to the
students afterwards in the pub and some
of them had said that they had to sneak
in or people had to sneak them into
Helen Joyce's talk mostly because they
didn't want to be seen by the activists
and they didn't want their lives to be
you know and so all of that's quite
depressing but they were all there were
a couple of them who really
fundamentally disagreed with me but
wanted to talk to me yeah yeah and I had
the same at Oxford at Oxford Union
actually there was a yeah there was a
girl who came up to me and she said so
do you think there's woke people in
Britain and I and I went yeah and she
went can you give me an example and I
gave her some examples oh okay you think
other work people in government I was
like yeah and sure can you give me some
examples I gave her some examples and
and then uh we had that conversation she
never formally agreed with me yeah but
she kept asking questions and it was
very clear that she hadn't thought or
researched any of this yeah but her
received wisdom was there's no wokeness
in the UK it's not a problem it's not an
issue it's not causing any problems
anyway afterwards she wanted to take a
picture with me yeah right now I don't
know what what else he's going to do
with that picture but my point is there
young people this is Claire Fox is very
good and every time I talked to Claire
about this she always kind of gives me a
a non-physical slap around the chops
because she's like you've got to
remember these are young people yeah the
minds are open to change and think about
their lives they've grown up in an
environment where they're surrounded by
people who have a certain opinion
they've never really had to question it
yeah but they they do know deep down
inside that if they are the one that
questions it their life's going to be
ruined by it so of course they have this
view But as time goes on as they're
exposed to different types of
information different types of content
different types of people is they meet
people like you
there is the possibility that you know
one out of a billion of them will change
their mind well I I hope it's more than
that and I think they will
the other problem of course is they've
got the academics people of my age and
older who are promoting this stuff in
those universities and it's been so sort
of there's such a consensus now of
idiocy among the staff
um and that doesn't help right so I
think I would blame my generation more
than the current gen younger younger I
really would I also I also am a you know
I'm pleased by the findings of groups
such as the more in common initiative
which has done a sort of very rigorous
study on the extent of wokeness if we
want to call it that roughly 13 of the
country would be classified as within
that identitarian work bracket and
that's a that means that they're a
minority in all generations
and you can see it when you go to these
universities you can see that you know
I asked one of the students whether you
would publish a uh an article in favor
of say LGB Alliance in the in the
University newspaper and they said no
but it wasn't because the majority of
students wouldn't agree it was because
there would be a very vocal minority who
would make their disagreement known in a
very unpleasant way so so as with all of
these things in terms of Corporations
and institutions and the Arts and the
media and universities it's a very vocal
and intimidating minority that seem to
hold the reins now there's a reason to
be optimistic there because of pure
numbers because of democracy because
ultimately once it becomes clear that
the majority are more sensible shall we
say then they will be more comfortable
expressing those viewpoints and I think
that's the way we're going and I think
from my interaction with students on on
the University campus they are like you
say and like Claire Fox rightly points
out far more open-minded and willing to
have discussions than people give them
credit for it's just that the minority
who are so active politically makes such
a noise and they're so boring and you
know and it's always been the way that's
not there's nothing new about that when
I was at University the the ones that
got into politics were were the boars
yeah they were they were the ones who
they loved the power you know they loved
like going around tearing down posters
that they disapproved of and you know
shaking their fists at people and stuff
you know they loved it but no one really
took them seriously and so I I think
well I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna be
optimistic today so maybe if you'd
caught me tomorrow I would have been
really negative but today I'm gonna be
really optimistic and say I think it's
down I think the future generation shows
us that there's a there's a way out and
eventually they will come around to the
reality I think yeah a good example of
this is my cousin was at Sussex yeah
when all of this nonsense with Kathleen
stock happened and my cousin it was a
young man he was very Progressive he was
very very very very very left-wing yeah
and he was walking through the square as
well say one of the squares in Sussex
whilst they were doing the demonstration
against her and they they all had black
balaclavas on yeah and he stopped and
looked him and went
I don't think these are the good guys no
exactly and he changed his mind and he
now loves trigonometry so there we go
and that's the result that's what you
want and that's how right-wing
indoctrination happens but Andrew on a
on a
pre-Christmas yeah personal no or
non-personal note what are you most
grateful for this year
one of my most grateful for
um because gratitude is something that
we've been thinking about a lot here I'm
grateful for a lot of things uh I'm I'm
in such a privileged position because I
get to my job is that I get to say what
I think for a living and it's so weird
you know I used to be a teacher
and there's no way I could that's my
line mate I've trademarked that I'm
sorry about that well that used to be
yes all our audience are massively fed
up with him saying I used to be a
teacher but you know a lot of you know
what it's like being a teacher and and
you are limited quite rightly because
you've entered into a contract you know
there's a certain way you behave but
like I couldn't be a teacher now not
just because of the way I tweet and the
way I talk and everything but also
because I'd be constantly battling these
stupid speakers that come into schools
to try and train you on unconscious bias
and stuff I don't have the temperament
to sit there and take it I would have to
tell them why they're wrong
um because the the the the the data's on
my side about that like we know that
unconscious bio sessions achieve
literally nothing and yet here is this
person coming in earning a fortune uh to
sell snake oil and I'd wanted I'd want
to say I and it would be I wouldn't ever
get promoted as a teacher now and I
wouldn't get anywhere and and it would
be constant battles and it would be
exhausting but I get to have those
battles on my own terms now and I get to
talk about and I get paid for it and and
it's it's so and it's a job I love and
that very few people have jobs that they
enjoy and I so I'm very grateful for
that and I'm very grateful for that I
can write the books I want to write and
get them published by a good publisher
that's really great as well
um it I feel like I'm free to say
whatever I want I haven't been censored
I don't think I will be I don't think I
can be and see Andrew there is no
problem with free speech in this country
there isn't for me but there is for so
many people and that's why yeah you know
well uh Andrew what we're grateful for
is having you back as I said for the
174th time yes no doubt we'll have you
back again everyone should get your
latest book the new Puritans which thank
you we've talked to you about and go
back and watch that episode and we are
going to do a few questions from our
local supporters yes that only they will
get to see the answers to
um but for now thank you for joining us
and thank you for watching and listening
we will see you uh very very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or show when we start them back up in
January and for those of you who like
your trig on the go I shouldn't I
trigonometry uh it's also available as a
podcast have a wonderful Christmas a
brilliant New Year and we can't wait to
see each and every one of you back in
2023 and this will probably go out after
Christmas so hope you've had a lovely
Christmas and we'll see you on locals in
a second
do you think at some point the left even
will become so embarrassed by wokism
that there will be attempts to frame it
as a right-wing position all along
foreign
[Music]